signe des temps et certains y ont vu une
provocation ce sont des militaires
soviétiques
c'est le 27 juin dernier le drapeau
olympique lors de l'inauguration du
village où seront hébergés les athlètes
et leurs délégations beaucoup sont déjà
installés d'autres comme les français
arriveront un peu plus tard dans cette
ville au milieu de la ville située à dix
kilomètres du centre de moscou laisse
porter vivront ici dans trois mille cinq
cent quarante appartements répartis dans
ces immeubles de 16 ou de 18 étages
signe des temps aussi l'inauguration
d'une église d'un temple d'une synagogue
et d'une mosquée à l'intérieur du
village il y a longtemps très longtemps
que la religion n'avait pas été à
pareille fête en union soviétique
ainsi à onze jours de l'ouverture
officielle des jeux tout est fin prêt
c'est particulièrement vrai au niveau
des installations sportives notamment au
stade loujniki où se déroulait le
week-end dernier le mémorial n'a mes
skis une rencontre amicale qui a permis
de vérifier que tout marchait bien les
tableaux d'affichage comme les
chronomètres
quant aux performances elles ont été
plus que modeste
mais c'est pas mal quand même
il en va de même à la piscine fin prête
elle aussi pour les épreuves de natation
bien que personne n'ait encore oser
plonger pour aller goûter la température
de l'eau
à la télévision par contre c'est le
branle bas de combat dans ses nouveaux
locaux ultramodernes et équipés de
matériel soviétique français et
américains les techniciens vérifier et
revérifier une deuxième fois que tout
est en place et à la bonne place ceci
afin d'éviter une charmante speakerine
qu'elle n'est au cours de ces jeux à
s'excuser d'une interruption momentanée
du son ou de l'image un travail de titan
et soviétiques et mettront jour et nuit
sur l'ensemble du monde
mais l'aspect le plus étonnant de ces
derniers préparatifs
c'est la ville elle-même une ville qui
s'habille pour recevoir ses visiteurs
les employés municipaux parmi lesquels
beaucoup de femmes ne savent plus où
donner de la tête certains repeignent la
signalisation des rues ou réparé la
chaussée d'autres vous allez le voir
tondre le gazon ou plante des arbres
d'autres enfin ravale certaines façades
d'immeubles celle en tout cas qui sont
de part et d'autre des grandes avenues
qu'emprunteront l'écart de tout bref
moscou veut être belle et elle le sera
sans doute pour ces jeux il faut dire
qu'on lui en a donné les moyens le maire
de la ville monsieur promis ce loft nous
a avoué que les jeux lui avait déjà
coûté 1 milliard et demi de roubles
mille milliards de centimes c'est le
prix de la grande fête olympique et
soviétiques qui commence dans onze jours
le 19 juillet